after the incident I was
I was shook I was shaking I was shaking
all night
I I couldn't believe what happened
well it was Chinese New Years we were
hosting a social dance party
uh I was in the lobby uh it was late
into the evening most of our customers
already left
uh I wasn't paying attention to the
front door I was looking into the dance
Ballroom the dance floor and this is
when I heard the sound of the front door
quick and closing and
instantly followed by the sound of a
metal object clinking together as if
they were rubbing that's when I turned
around and saw that there was an Asian
man holding a gun
my first thoughts was I was going to die
here
this was it this was somebody I have
never seen before
he didn't seem like he was here for any
money he wasn't here to Rob us
when he was uh looking around a room it
seemed like he was looking for targets
people to harm
um this is when he started prepping his
weapon and
if something came over me I realized
I needed to get the weapon away from him
I needed to take this weapon disarm him
or else everybody would have died
um when I got the courage I lunged at
him with both my hands
grabbed the weapon
and we had a struggle we struggled into
the lobby
trying to get this gun away from each
other he was hitting me across the face
bashing the back of my head
I I was trying to use my elbows to
separate the gun away from him creating
some distance
finally at one point I was able to pull
the gun away from him shove him aside
create some distance
point the gun at him intimidate him shot
him and say
get the hell out here I'll shoot
get away go
and at this point I thought he would run
away but he was just standing there
contemplating whether to fight or to run
away
I really thought I would have to shoot
him he came at me
this is when he
turned around and walked out the door
dropped back to his van
I immediately called police with the gun
still in my hand
I I noticed there was bruising all over
my body my face has a bruise across the
nose and the back of my head has some
bruising
I can't believe that this could happen
well a lot of people have been telling
me how
much courage I had to confront a
situation like this
but you know what courage is courage is
not the abstinence fear but rather the
ability to have adversity to fear when
fear fearful events happen such as this
and in crisis like this the people need
courage especially the victims their
friends their families
my heart goes out to everybody involved
especially the people
in Star Dan studio
and Monterey Park I hope they could find
the courage
and the strength to persevere